munich allemagne le 5 septembre les jeux
olympiques symbole de la fraternité
internationale tourner la tragédie il ya
eu des terroristes qui ont attaqué le
village les résidences d israël pour la
remettre en haltérophilie philippe saint
cyr ce sont ses premiers jeux olympiques
son premier voyage en europe à rêves qui
va se transformer en cauchemar
genre plus des otages
aujourd'hui qu'ils avaient probablement
des morts pierre dufau faisait partie de
l'équipe de radio canada qui couvrait
les jeux olympiques et il ya eu des
tractations et se sont parlés tâter
puisque ils s'entendaient pas
finalement on sait qu'ils vont partir
aéroport militaire de furane feuilles
bruch reprenait l'avion le 5 septembre
1912 charles biétry et journaliste à l'
agence france-presse au parent à
l'aéroport et dazu coup j'entends mois
des coups de feu
et à un moment une germe bleu dans le
ciel
serait après que ces commentaires qui
explose et puis le silence
je suis très content car autant que je
sache cette opération de police et un
succès tout à coup nous arrive une
dépêche la radio allemande vient
d'annoncer qu' il ya eu solution il ya
eu entente échange de prisonniers bref
de défini tout est beau tout est parfait
en egypte bravo on retrouvait moi j'ai
entendu des coups de feu moi j'ai vu
cette gerbe dans le ciel était forcément
excusons chez pas de quoi mais ils
peuvent pâtir qui sait rien qui s'est
rien passé et que tout va bien
et puis un moment
j'arrive devant une petite porte côté de
s'ouvre et serein à monsieur le visage
sombre
avec des larmes qui coulent
excusez-moi 1 est toujours un peu mal
sur eux
sur ce moment là et donc
j'ai à lui
une demande qui est doux et répond un
sucre aux habitants le maire de mick vié
qu'est ce qui s'est passé et et me
répond
zinal tôt tu es sont tous forts
wir haben la sphère passe on a tout raté
c'est
super création totale pour moi puisque
il devait tout dire que tout s'était
bien passé
donc je viens de savoir l'opération de
libération
qui avait été prévu par la police
allemande
bah ça n'a pas marché et c'est
épouvantable ce qui vient de passer
tous les otages qu'ils sont des haltes
et israéliens des jeux olympiques son
bord
c'est cet ancien journaliste de l afp
qui va annoncer la dramatique nouvelle
au monde entier elle a même atteint on
se lève croyais à que tout revient la
normale et c'est la khl la nouvelle
tombe short soit les autorités
allemandes disent maintenant qu'il y
avait 11 otages
deux ont été tués dans leur chambre hier
matin neuf ont été tuées à l'aéroport ce
soit thonaille ils sont tous morts
ici robert frosi radio canada n'ont rien
[Musique]